how does this mean this to a computer  the video you're watching now is made up  of tiny pixels on your screen each pixel  has a red green and blue light which add  together to produce what your eyes see  as a single color hex tells the computer  how much of each light to use it's a six  digit code with three parts one for red  green and blue the letters A through F  are used to represent the numbers 10  through 15 so that more than 99 values  can be held in two digits now in action  e8 is the red value each digit must be  multiplied with 16 to the power of its  place since hex is a base 16 system so  first we have 8 times 16 to the 0th  power  next is e so 14 times 16 to the first  power added together the computer knows  to set the red light to 232 this process  is continued until the computer knows  how much of red green and blue to show  for each of the millions of pixels every  fraction of a second